Alright, our scripture today is Ephesians 5. The worship guide says verse 13, we're
going to start in verse 1.
Therefore, be imitators of God as beloved children, and walk in love as Christ loved
us, and gave himself up for us, a fragrant offering and sacrifice to God.
But sexual immorality and all impurity or covetness must not be named among you, as
is proper among saints.
There be no filthiness or foolish talk nor crude joking which are out of place, but instead
let there be thanksgiving.
For you may be sure of this that everyone who is sexually immoral or impure or who is covetous
has no inheritance in the kingdom of Christ and God.
Let no one deceive you with empty words, for because of these things the wrath of
God comes upon the sons of disobedience.
Therefore, do not become partners with them for at one time you were darkness, but
now you are light in the Lord.
Walk as children of light, and try to discern what is pleasing to the Lord.
Take no part in the unfruitful works of darkness, but instead expose them, for it is shameful
even to think of the things they do in secret.
But when anything is exposed by the light, it becomes visible, for anything that becomes
visible is light.
Therefore it says, Awake, O sleeper, and arise from the dead, and Christ will
shine in you.
Thank you, Cole.
Let's pray together.
Lord, you are our light and our salvation.
Your word is a lamp into our feet and a light into our path.
Your spirit enlightens our hearts.
And, Lord, I pray that we would know your presence among us, we would know your light.
I want to pray that we would see the light of your glory revealed in the face of Jesus.
We pray all of this in His name.
Amen.
Well, this morning we're going to look at what it means to walk in the light.
Last week we were looking at what it means to walk in love, and now we're seeing what
it means to walk in the light.
I nearly requested this morning that we sing the old country gospel song, I Saw the
Light.
Do you know that one?
Maybe we can do that next week.
If you're not familiar with it, I'm sure Will Nolton would be glad to sing
it for you if you wouldn't mind.
I'm not going to sing it this morning, but it begins.
I wondered so aimless, life filled with sin.
I wouldn't let my dear Savior in.
Then Jesus came like a stranger in the night.
Praise the Lord.
I saw the light.
Song's got a lot of biblical truth in it, but it was written in maybe a surprising
setting if you've not heard the story before.
It was written by none other than the legendary Alabamian Hank Williams, Sr.
Actually, what happened was he got really, really drunk and had to be driven home from
one of his concerts.
When you get near to where he lived, there was a little airport that was there, and there
was a kind of beacon light that was there.
The person driving him woke him up.
They said, Hank, we're near your house now.
I just saw the light.
He woke up in between seeing the light in the distance and getting to his house.
He wrote, I wondered so aimless.
He wrote, I saw the light.
Well, there were some contradictions in his life to say the least.
There was an awareness of the light, but a struggle to walk in the light.
Actually, really sad story near the end of his life.
He was once again in that same kind of state that he was when he wrote the song.
And this time he was being driven around by a country singer called Minnie Pearl.
And he was really depressed looking out the window.
And Minnie was trying to cheer him up.
But she said, Hank, why don't you sing?
I saw the light with me.
And then in kind of sadness still looking out, he said, Minnie, I don't see no light.
There ain't no light.
And it was pretty shortly after that he died.
I'm not here to make a pronouncement on whether or
not Hank Williams ever truly saw the light of Christ.
But there is a struggle that you see in him between an awareness of the light.
Like I said, walking in the light.
And if you're honest, I'd imagine you would see that struggle in your own self.
Because I certainly see it in mine, being aware of the light,
but struggling to walk in it.
But scripture makes it clear that followers of Christ are those who have not
only seen the light, but those who walk in the light.
So here what the apostle Paul says once again in Ephesians 5 and verse 8.
He says to believers, at one time you were darkness, but now you are light in the Lord.
Walk as children of light.
It's recalled to walk in the light as God's people.
So why should we walk in the light?
Well, first thing we see here is we should walk in the light because you are light.
If you are a Christian, you are light.
We're to walk as children of light because that is the only way that is consistent with
who we now are in Christ.
So he says at one time you were darkness, but now you are light in the Lord.
Now if you've been with us these past few months or you're just familiar with the book of Ephesians,
it will not be any surprise that Paul goes here.
This is what he's told us all along.
He's showing us that this is who you were.
Now this is who you are.
In other words, walking in the light is first of all about our identity.
He goes here again.
So notice first of all how Paul describes the human condition apart from Christ.
He doesn't say you had a bit of darkness in you.
It's not like the dimmer switches down and you need to kind of turn it up a little bit.
The light of divinity might shine a bit more brightly in your life.
No, he says you were darkness categorically.
So sin involves our actions.
Yes, if you look at the text you'll see it tells us about things that we do being sinful.
It speaks about disobedience against God.
It speaks about the unfruitful works of darkness.
We'll look at those in a moment.
But even more fundamental than our actions is who we are.
The problem of sin goes right down to the core of our being.
It isn't just something we do.
It's the outworking of our identity.
So why is this important?
Is this just like splitting hairs over like a particular doctrine, the doctrine of sin?
I'm going to say no, it isn't just splitting hairs on that.
Because if we are going to see the kind of change that we need, we need to understand the
kind of problem that we have.
If the problem is merely outward or behavioral, then it makes sense to just work on the outward
appearance, to just work on our behaviors.
But the problem is deeper than that.
And if it's deeper than that, we need a more radical transformation.
We need a new life entirely.
Earlier this week Julia kindly informed me that the lights were now not only out in our
bathroom but also in the children's bathroom upstairs.
Maybe I should have already been aware of this, but she kindly let me know.
And I heard her.
Now I am no electrician, but I went to investigate what the issue was.
And I quickly ascertained that the light bulbs needed to be changed.
And I know how to do that.
And we have light bulbs.
And so, being the superhero, I am, I went and changed the lights for us finally.
And but you know, it wouldn't have made a difference if one of the light bulbs was kind of smashed
or it looked fine on the outside.
If it's broke, it needs to be changed, right?
We needed new light bulbs entirely.
So similarly, you might look at one person and be like, yeah, they are living in the
darkness like a kind of shattered light bulb.
Like they are darkness.
You might look at this other person over here who looks to be a moral upright person and
think, well, surely they are light.
Or it's actually, it's not the case.
You can have people appearing differently in their behaviors and yet still be in the
darkness.
You know, I went in both of those bathrooms and all the light bulbs were just as dark
as the rest.
So it's fundamental to who we are apart from Christ.
Our sin cuts us off from the source of light.
And just as living things cannot survive without light, so to be in the darkness is to be dead
in your sin.
That's our condition.
But it says, but now you are light.
This is your identity now.
This is another way of saying, by the way, what he says in verse three when he says
that you are saints, right?
We saw that earlier in Ephesians.
The word saints means God's holy people.
You are holy now.
So how can it be said that we are holy, that we are now light, that we're pure?
What's because, notice where our light comes from.
Our light comes from the Lord.
It comes from the Lord.
He says, but now you are light in the Lord.
If you change the lights, like the light bulb doesn't come out of the box shining,
right?
It's got to be screwed in to the sockets.
It needs to have a source of electricity.
So our light comes from being in the Lord because God is light.
Well, maybe that's even more confusing.
Well, what does it mean to say that God is light?
Well, this is a fascinating theme that stretches from Genesis to Revelation right the way
throughout Scripture.
And maybe we'll return to that soon.
But just to draw out a couple of things from what we see across the whole of Scripture.
One is that light, to say that God is light is speaking of His holiness.
So 1 John chapter one, verse five says God is light and in Him is no darkness at all.
So that's to say that God is perfectly holy all the time in every way.
He is absolutely pure.
It is who He is.
That's very different to what we said about our own sinfulness.
God is holy.
But light not only speaks about God's holiness, it also speaks about His guiding presence.
So you see this especially in the book of Exodus.
So you take the burning bush for example where God meets with Moses.
And of course, this light is emanating from this bush, this fire, and it's a
holy place, right?
Because God's holiness again, Moses takes off his shoes because it's holy ground.
But there God speaks to him.
He reveals who He is to Moses.
And He tells him about what His plans are for His people to save them.
Right, here's what I'm going to do.
You then have the Exodus happens and then there's the wilderness wandering and God
is present among His people in the wilderness.
He's leading them.
But how could His guiding presence be seen?
You know, a pillar of cloud by day and a pillar of fire by night is guiding His people.
And then you have the giving of the law.
So Moses goes up to Mount Sinai but we also see God descending onto Mount Sinai.
And the appearance of His glory there, we're told, is like a devouring fire.
So light is emanating from this mountain.
And there God gives Moses the law.
When Moses comes down, he speaks his God's word to his people.
Moses' own face is shining as he speaks the word of the Lord, God guiding his people in
the light.
So when Jesus comes into the world, we see the light of God.
Jesus says, John chapter 8 and verse 12, I am the light of the world.
Whoever follows me will not walk in darkness but will have the light of life.
So that's where we see God's perfection is in Christ.
That is where we see His guiding presence is in Jesus coming to be with us.
So the God who dwells in inapproachable light is present with us, present with us in the
person of Jesus Christ.
And those who saw Him said, we beheld His glory.
The glory is of the only begotten of the Father.
We can behold that glory now because here's how Scripture speaks of conversion.
It speaks of us coming to Jesus by saying that the Spirit of God shines in our hearts that
we too might behold the glory of God in the face of Jesus.
When we behold that glory, when we know God's holy presence with us making Jesus known
to us, we are now in the light in the Lord.
So we're united to the light of the world by faith.
And in Him we are light.
We are holy because we've been made holy in Him.
We are now pure.
We are light in the Lord.
So to be are.
But what does it mean to walk in the light?
Because we're called to like walk in the light.
You are light.
So walk in the light.
Or walk as children of light it says here.
I was talking to somebody the other day who had looked around a house.
It was a student accommodation essentially.
They were walking around and there were some other students still living there.
And they were said the students just didn't seem to be prepared for anybody to come
and look at this house.
And they said they even went up to one of the bedrooms, I guess with the realtor,
and it was just pitch black and somebody was sat there in the darkness.
And they said would you mind if I just pull back the curtains?
Because so I could see the room.
And they said yeah, yeah, go ahead.
So they pulled back the curtain and let some light in.
And before they left, they said do you want us to pull the curtain back?
And I said yes, please.
So they pulled the curtain back.
So this person had access to all the light they needed,
but they wanted to sit in darkness.
Well here we're seeing like you are light in the world.
So draw back the curtain.
And walk in the light that is yours in Jesus.
If His holy presence is with us and guiding us, then we should follow Him.
It's interesting that the language of family is also used here.
You know, that's how we started back at the start of chapter five,
speaking of us as children of God, beloved children of God.
And now it says that we are children of light.
So if God is light, then His children are light.
So something of His likeness should be reflected in us.
All right, so this is put before us here.
What it means to walk in the light by showing us the contrast between darkness and light.
There's a, this walking in darkness is a total contradiction with our new identity.
But walking in the light corresponds with this new identity if we are light.
And he wants us to see both of them clearly here.
So first of all, let's look at the unfruitful works of darkness.
We're going to know what it means to walk in the light.
What it will mean knowing what darkness is and having the light of God shining on that darkness
to expose it for what it is.
So it talks about things being out of place for children of light.
So if you notice in chapter five and verse three,
it talks about things that are not proper among saints.
So don't think of that word proper as like proper table etiquette and like a fancy meal or something like that.
Well, what that essentially means is there's things that don't fit.
That's what the word means.
It's like, you know, trying to crank your car with a house key.
Like it's just, it's just not going to work.
They don't go together.
It also talks about things not being named among God's people.
And it's not saying they should be kept quiet.
It's just saying they have no place whatsoever.
They don't fit to the degree that there's zero place for it.
You know, it's like if somebody has a peanut allergy, it's not like, oh, there was just one peanut there.
Like, like if it's serious, it's serious.
Like there's no place for it.
And they give some specific examples.
So let's go through the specific examples he gives just like he did in chapter four.
He does here.
So in verse three starts off by talking about sexual immorality and all impurity.
So what is sexual immorality?
What's any sexual activity that is outside the marriage covenant between a man and a woman?
Then impurity is a broader category of lust that includes all kinds of lust.
So just to be clear, God is not against sex.
He created it as a good gift, but it is reserved for the context of marriage.
That's what it is for.
And so as Paul is writing this, he's writing this to people where they're in a society, in a culture where promiscuity was fairly common.
And it was even part of religious practices in their day.
And if they were going to be God's holy people, they were not to take part in that, however cultural it was.
Now things may look different in our day than they did in the day in which Ephesians was written.
But I don't think any of us would deny that this is a major thing in our culture today as well.
It is an issue.
We're in a culture where it seems that we're moving in a direction where just about anything goes as long as it is between consenting adults.
But this is here once again, not to just critique our culture, but to see that these things can creep into the church as well.
It can be in the form of outright affirming sexual immorality or keeping it hidden away, like not talking about it.
Actually the word used for sexual immorality here is porneia, which is where we get our word pornography.
While the use of porn is not an accepted practice in the church, it is all too common in people's private lives.
And it needs to be brought into the light.
It needs to be seen for what it is.
Sexual immorality.
But it also speaks of covetousness, covetousness or greed.
That must not be named either.
So what is covetousness?
Well, it's the unrestrained desire for more.
It's like feeling like I don't have enough and I've got to have something beyond what I already have.
And the thing is, like you can talk about greed and people think, well, that just doesn't apply to me.
I think the reason that is is because in our, we live in a materialistic culture and we think that we don't struggle with this because it is so pervasive.
It is the waters that we are swimming in, in the West.
One commentator described this as the great, unconfessed sin of the Western middle classes.
It can take all different forms.
It can take the form of excessive spending where we feel like we've got to have the best or the latest or the newest or whatever.
We have a craving and we think that that will satisfy that particular craving.
So it fills our thoughts, the thing that we want to get.
But another way this can happen is more hidden.
It can take the form of like hoarding to satisfy our longing for security.
And that even feels like responsible.
It's like responsible covetousness.
Like I've got to have more in the stockpile.
So there's that the kind of outward lavishness, but there's also the hidden security.
It's fascinating that sexual sins have a stigma attached to them, you know, in evangelical churches.
But excessive indulgence in these areas or that kind of hoarding mentality is not seen as a big deal, but it is.
He even says here that those who are covetous are verse five idolaters.
Covetousness is described as idolatry.
And this puts its finger when he calls it idolatry both on sexual immorality and covetousness.
Because if you look at the 10 commandments, the 10th commandment is do not covet.
And one of the things is like do not covet your neighbor's wife.
And it goes on to list other things.
Right. So this is an all-encompassing thing for not being satisfied with what you have.
Okay. And it puts its finger on the issue because the big issue here is what are you worshiping?
What are we worshiping?
Are we devoted to God?
Are we devoted to our desires for other things?
Are our thoughts filled with Him and His beauty and His glory?
Or are they filled with something else?
The question is also like, is He enough?
Or do we feel we have to have these other things?
Hebrews chapter 13 and verse five says, keep your life free from the love of money.
And be content with what you have.
Well, how can we do that?
It then goes on to say, for He Himself, God Himself has said,
I will never leave you or forsake you.
He also moves on to talk about our speech.
He says, let no verse four filthiness nor foolish talk nor crude joking.
So course language or off-color humor is what is being referred to here.
Talk about something that has become commonplace in our day, not just in private,
but in public discourse as well.
Things are excused as, oh, it's just locker room talk,
as though that was an okay way to speak.
That's just how people talk these days.
This has no place in the speech of those who are children of light.
Being edgy in our language does not promote grace.
Jesus says, out of the abundance of the heart, the mouth speaks.
He said that in Luke chapter six, verse 45.
So our words are an indication of the condition of our hearts.
And if we speak in these ways, it demonstrates that we really don't see sin
as being as serious or as dangerous as it truly is.
I read about someone who was on vacation.
And while they were there, they saw this little snake on the beach.
And they picked it up and they had some pictures with it.
They even kissed the snake and had a nice time put it down.
And they didn't find out until afterwards when they posted it online
that that snake was a sea snake.
That was 10 times as venomous as any rattlesnake.
And so they literally had death in their hands, not realizing.
So we see this here in the text.
Paul is saying, this is what sin is and here is how serious it is.
Here's how dangerous it is.
Verse five, what does it say?
He says, you may be sure of this that everyone who is sexually immoral or
impure or who is covetous, that is an idolatry.
Here's how serious it is.
Has no inheritance in the kingdom of Christ and God.
It also says, because of these things, the wrath of God comes upon
the sons of disobedience.
So the God who is lied is also a consuming fire, we read about in
Deuteronomy chapter nine in verse three, fire destroys.
It's also a picture of judgments.
So people may try to deceive us into thinking these things are not really
sinful or they may downplay God's judgments and they may even do so from a pulpit.
Some may even celebrate sinful ways of life as freedom, but
Scripture says, do not be deceived by their empty words.
So you have this word of warning, those who practice these things will not inherit
the kingdom.
Instead, they will receive the wrath of God.
But could also give a word of assurance here.
Remember this is written to Christians.
So if Christians need to be told to not practice these things,
implicit in that is that we fail in these areas.
We do sin.
Those who do not enter the kingdom are those for whom this is a settled habitual
practice.
It's talking about a way of life that is habitual.
So this is different to struggling with sin as a believer.
So the point here is not that we don't fall or that we don't fail.
We do, we will.
But the difference is instead of keeping our sins hidden away in sin,
the difference is instead of keeping our sins hidden away in the dark,
we bring them out into the light.
We confess our sins, 1 John 1 and verse 9 says, we confess our sins knowing that
He is faithful and just to forgive us of our sins and to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness.
We don't hold on to them.
Yes, we fail, but we go to war with our sin and we bring them into the light
and we are Christ in confession and receiving His cleansing.
But we also recognize as we do that that these ways of darkness do not correspond
with being children of light.
But there is a way that does correspond to that.
He speaks not only of the fruit of the works of darkness,
He speaks of the fruit of light here as well.
You see that in verse 9, the fruit of light is found in all that is good
and righteous and true.
So this is not just about what we refuse.
It's also about what we replace.
So we're refusing the darkness.
We see the danger of that, but we also see the goodness of what God has laid
before us and we pursue those better things.
So there's a positive motivation here.
You see that in what He says about our speech in verse 4.
So if you go back to that, so let's not have this filthiness or foolish talk
or crude joking be part of our speech, but instead let there be what?
Thanksgiving.
So Thanksgiving is the opposite of desiring more than what you have been given.
So someone who is giving thanks is someone who sees how amazing what they already have is.
They see the grace of God and they give Him thanks for that.
Right? So they're not just saying, I don't do that.
I don't talk that way.
They're saying something that's so much better than giving God thanks for it.
So if we're walking in the light, we see and savor what God has already given us.
Three quick things He's given us.
Best of all, He's given us Himself.
He is our exceeding joy.
He is the one, the only one who can satisfy our hunger and our thirst.
He fully satisfies.
But He's also the God who gives us good things.
Every good gift comes from Him.
We read in James 1.
So He helps us to appreciate and enjoy all of the good gifts He has given us.
That can obviously mean we can and should enjoy spiritual things like our Bibles,
but He also gives us a capacity to enjoy the material things that He has given us as well.
Instead of craving the things that are beyond our reach,
we really see what we have now and we enjoy it with a greater depth.
And we give Him thanks.
That could be our friendships.
It could be our spouse.
It could be our children.
It could be things out in nature.
Whatever it is for you,
He helps us to see and enjoy beauty in the so-called ordinary.
We see His glory reflected in what is before us.
We also see the good that He's given us in His righteousness.
So the fruit of light is seeking out what is good and right and true.
It is seeing the beauty of holiness and seeking to live it out by God's grace.
So walk in the light.
But what happens when we as children of light walk in the light?
So we are light.
We walk in the light.
Then what?
The last thing I want to see is that we shine as light in the world.
So light serves a purpose beyond shining.
It guides as we've seen already.
A few months ago, our family went out to Oak Mountain State Park
and we went camping together.
And it was great.
Really enjoyed it.
And the year before we went,
we had a little walk around the place.
And I took the kids on a nighttime hike on a trail.
And we had the flashlight out walking around.
But this time we went and we took the flashlights.
And all of a sudden we realized we didn't even need the flashlights
because there was a full moon and it was so bright
and it was reflecting off the water as well.
We could walk through the trail because of the light that was reflected.
The light that was reflected,
the light of the sun reflected on the moon,
gave us all that we need to show the way to go.
It's God's desire that His people reflect His light,
not just for themselves,
but also so that others in the world may come to know Him as well.
You see this in what He says to the people of Israel in Isaiah 49 and verse 6.
He says,
It is too light a thing that you should be my servant
to raise up the tribes of Jacob and bring back the preserved of Israel.
I will make you as a light for the nations
that my salvation may reach to the end of the earth.
You see this then in how Jesus describes His disciples.
Matthew chapter 5 and verse 14,
He says,
You are the light of the world.
You're like a city set on a hill.
You're like a lamp in a house.
Like you don't hide the light.
You let it show in the world
that others may come to glorify your Father too.
The apostle Peter speaks of the church as being the light.
He talks about how God has made us His own,
1 Peter 2.9,
that you may proclaim the excellencies of Him
who called you out of darkness
and into His marvelous light.
So God makes us lights so that we might make His salvation
known to a world that is lost in darkness.
We're not called to be partakers of the ways of the world,
but we are called to be present in the world
that they too might come to know Christ.
But notice how it's drawn out in this text specifically.
He talks about how light exposes the works of darkness.
Verse 11 says,
Take no part in the unfruitful works of darkness,
but instead expose them.
So turning on a light exposes what is hidden in the darkness.
And if our lives are reflecting the light of Christ,
it will expose the sinful ways of life
that are hidden in darkness in the world.
Now Paul doesn't specify as to how to go about this here,
but you can see examples of this in Scripture
of how this can happen both in word and deed.
So our deeds can shine a light that exposes.
So our lives should have such a distinct quality
that it exposes the lostness of those that we are around.
It's possible to be a joyful yet sometimes convicting presence
merely by the way that you live around others
who are living differently.
The light can also come through in our words.
There will be times when we are to speak
in ways that expose the sin of the world.
This is of course true societally.
It does the church no favors to take a neutral middle ground stance
on issues of clear right and wrong.
And it's even worse when we do that with our own tribe,
be it like a theological tribe or political tribe,
as though we're perfect and only just calling out the sins of others.
So we need to bring sin out into the light,
but also personally in our conversation with somebody,
it may be right sometimes to shed the light
of God's word on what they are doing.
It's sometimes right to look at someone in the eye
and speak the truth about their sin to them.
Now that doesn't mean you walk around the office
like you're the moral police, you know, calling people out
for anything to get wrong or something like that.
That's not what it's saying here.
But this does sometimes mean speaking clearly
about the reality of sin and the coming judgments.
We don't do this from a place of moral superiority,
but from a place of love.
So people need to know that they are lost
if they're going to see the need to be saved.
And if we're going to do that, we need to begin with ourselves,
speaking of our own sin and our own need for the gospel.
It's kind of like if you've got somebody who's lost
out in the wilderness and somebody comes to find them
with a flashlight and they find them,
the light reveals, yes, their lostness,
but it's also their salvation in it too.
So we, yes, expose the sinfulness, the lostness of the world,
but we do so that they might see the light of the gospel.
So light leads to, it doesn't just expose,
it leads to transformation and awakening.
We want people to experience the transformation
that we have experienced.
So we see that in the start of verse 14.
It says, for anything that becomes visible is light.
So the hope is that when the light exposes the dire condition
that people are in, that they will not retreat into the shadows,
but remain in the light.
And if they remain in the light, we see that they become light.
This can be a bit confusing thinking about what this is saying here,
but it seems to be pointing to a transformation, becoming light.
So we long that people hear the gospel
and they then confess their sins and then they move from being darkness
to now being light in the Lord as we saw earlier.
Then Paul goes on to quote something that's quite poetic.
There at the end of verse 14, we'll end here.
He says, this is therefore it says,
This is likely an early hymn or confession.
Some people think it was used at baptisms.
I don't know.
But it's essentially a mashup of different truths from Isaiah
that points to the light of Jesus.
Here's the idea.
We are asleep, even dead in our sins.
But then the light of Christ breaks through.
We see his glory.
We awake from slumber.
We see the light of Christ.
We see the light of glory.
We awake from slumber and are given this new life in him.
And in his light, we not only see who he is,
we also see reality as it truly is.
So we're calling out to people to wake up from their sleep,
that the light of Christ might shine on them too.
So we want to bring the light of the gospel to bear on our own lives
and to give glory to those who are in heaven.
And we want to bring the light of Christ to them too.
So in the words of Jesus,
let your light so shine before others
that they may see your good works
and give glory to your Father who is in heaven.
Let's pray.
Lord, you are light.
And in you is no darkness.
And in you is no fellowship with one another.
And the blood of Jesus Christ cleanses us from all sin.
And so Lord, I pray that you call us out from the shadows
into your glorious light.
Lord, we know that you expose us in our sin.
Not that we might live in shame,
but that we might receive cleansing in Jesus.
That we would look away from our sinfulness even now to you.
And we would behold your glory revealed in Jesus.
Lord, help us to see how wonderful you are.
And may we follow you as children of light.
In Jesus' name, amen.